[موسيقى
] إن
imac الجديد كليًا المعاد تصميمه
شخصيًا
أكثر قوة وقدرة من أي وقت مضى
، وهو أمر لا يصدق من كل
زاوية يتفجر بالألوان من
الأمام والخلف
ويختفي عمليًا عند
مشاهدته من الجانب للمقارنة
دعنا نلقي نظرة على imac السابق ،
كانت لوحة المنطق
والحرارة ضخمة بسبب المعالج الجائع للطاقة
ووحدة المعالجة المركزية gpu والمكونات الأخرى
كانت جميعها شرائح منفصلة في النظام
الآن مع النظام على بنية رقاقة
m1 تم دمجها جميعًا في  هذه
اللوحة المنطقية الأصغر حجمًا
، والنتيجة هي تصميم أكثر
إحكاما ونحافة 11.5 ملم فقط ،
يمكنك الاختيار من بين ثلاثة أنواع من
لوحات المفاتيح مع حاويات رائعة من الألمنيوم
تتطابق مع ألوان إيماك ، أولاً ، توجد
لوحة مفاتيح سحرية
مع إملاء رموز تعبيرية جديدة
ولا تزعج المفاتيح
ومفتاح قفل لقفل imac على الفور ، وبعد ذلك
توجد لوحة مفاتيح سحرية مع
ميزة جديدة ومثيرة
معرف اللمس الذي يأتي  بالنسبة لسطح مكتب Mac
لأول مرة ،
يتميز الماوس السحري الذي يحبه مستخدمو imac الآن بألوان متطابقة من الألومنيوم
ولوحة تتبع سحرية لا تزال إلى حد بعيد
أفضل ما في الصناعة
يتمتع بشكل مصقول ليلائم لوحة المفاتيح الجديدة ،
حيث يبدأ
من 12.99 فقط بأربعة ألوان وبسعر
14.99
imac يأتي  في سبعة ألوان مع هذه
الميزات الإضافية ،
يمكنك طلب imac الجديد بدءًا من
30 أبريل
وسيكون متاحًا في النصف الثاني
من مايو